hi this is steve kaufman again uh
talking about the seven secrets to
successful language learning
uh you'll remember the first secret was
to spend the time every day if possible
and for a long enough period of time to
achieve your goals
the second secret in my opinion is to do
what you like doing
this is very important if you don't
enjoy
studying the language you won't put in
the time
so it's important that you do the things
that you like doing
now i can tell you what i like doing
but i can't tell you that you should do
what i like doing because you may not
like doing them what i like doing what i
think is extremely effective is
listening and reading
okay
i think that when you are listening and
reading you're relying entirely on your
imagination
to convert all these words into meaning
and so to me that is a more intense
learning environment than say watching
videos
but there are other people who like to
watch videos and who will watch videos
over and over again i can't do that so
it's not something that i should do
because i don't like doing it
similarly someone who doesn't like
listening or reading
to my mind they're missing out on
something they probably feel the same
with me about not watching videos but
they should then do what they like to do
i see advice and i should i'll continue
a little bit on the listening and
reading and my strategy there
when i start out with the language i
will listen quite often
to
short bits of content
until i understand 50 60 70 70 then i'll
move on to the next item so i'll listen
quite often to beginner content i always
want to read whatever i listen to and i
want to
listen to whatever i read
certainly in the beginning period that's
what i like doing
um the other thing is i i listen to
things that i like i listen to content
where i like the voice
uh i listen to things that i'm
interested in so i very much like to do
what i like to do and that keeps me
going um i know there are some people
who like to speak right away i don't
like doing that so i don't do it
uh
there are some people who like to write
who like to answer questions i hate
answering questions drills you know find
the verb redo this sentence or
comprehension questions about what i
have listened to or read
some people like to translate
i know looka who's an excellent uh
polyglot
likes to
translate what he has just listened to
into his own language i don't like doing
that so i think to be a successful
language learner
you have to enjoy the process you have
to put in the time so you have to decide
what it is you like doing do you like
listening and reading do you like
watching videos do you like just going
out and hanging out with people if that
opportunity is available to you as i
said i personally
i don't like doing a lot of speaking
until i have enough of the language
enough words enough familiarity with the
language but others do
so it is important to do what you like
to do
that's going to be a major
uh condition
for success because if you like doing it
then all of a sudden
it's the process of language learning
that becomes its own reward
and as
one link member said when i met him in
osaka japan he said in language learning
there's no finish line it's the process
itself that is the reward if we do what
we like to do so that's my second secret
in language learning do what you like to
do but continue doing it